au coeur de la ville et des débats
dernier rebondissement du feuilleton de
la deuxième ligne de tramway cette
lettre de la préfète adressé début avril
à wilfrid schwarz président du syndicat
des mobilités touraine en l'état actuel
du projet la compatibilité d'un passage
du tramway par le boulevard béranger
présente des difficultés avec les
dispositions du plan de sauvegarde et ne
permet pas d'envisager un avis favorable
de l'architecte des bâtiments de france
à une demande de permis d'aménager dans
son argumentaire la représentante de
l'état soulève la question de la
suppression des arbres sur les
alignements extérieure au niveau des
places de parking selon elle ces
abattages doivent être justifiées par
une amélioration du lieu pour se
conformer au plan de sauvegarde de la
ville un document d'urbanisme qui
concerne le centre historique de tours
des éléments que la spat lui aurait
fourni
donc on lui avait fait un courrier
recommandé
assez développée en lui mettant tous les
inconvénients de ce passager tous les
antécédents dans deux autres dans
d'autres villes avec les jurisprudences
elle selon prend apparemment bien compte
de l'impossibilité de passer par ce type
de trajet impossible aussi de se passer
de l'état grands financeurs de cette
seconde ligne de tramway mais pour la
dtt au contraire ce courrier ne remet
pas en cause le projet sous sa forme
actuelle pour l'association le boulevard
béranger profiterez de cet aménagement
car aujourd'hui plus que le patrimoine
architectural c'est surtout la voiture
qui est mise en valeur un
éclaircissement du des bars apporte des
éléments dont on avait besoin dans le
débat le tabou du remplacement des
arbres élevé on peut en parler c'était
pas du tout évoqué jusqu'à maintenant
était pas question toucher aux armes
soit on fait une ligne entière son nom
fait pas du tout donc on peut pas partir
sur la thèse de faire une demi-ligne ça
c'est très important parce qu'il y en a
beaucoup qui partaient sur cette thèse
là car en parallèle la commission
nationale des débats vient de rendre son
avis à la préfète si le tracé prévu
n'est finalement pas retenu il faudra
reprendre le projet à la racine avec une
nouvelle enquête publique pour le
nouveau tracé